this is the malpath role
it's about as tall as the empire state
building and it's three and a half times
the length of a football field the
moorpath role essentially is a thank you
note to lord morphith who was the chief
secretary of ireland from about 1835 to
41. it was estimated at the time that it
had 270 000 signatures making it one of
the largest such testimonials in
existence provided to george howard
vicar
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm quentin atkinson senior director of
global content at ancestry and this is
the archival vault at ancestry
the content team is responsible for
finding out where documents exist
throughout the world that could provide
discoveries for people we then digitize
records and then we create searchable
indexes
the more path role is important because
it captures a group of people in ireland
pre the 1845 famine but also because in
1922 a lot of the records documenting
people with an island were destroyed by
fire during the civil war of ireland the
moorpath role really is a census
substitute for those that lived at that
time in ireland
i am professor terence dooley principal
investigator of the morphin role project
the morbid role is a token of gratitude
for the reforms that have been
introduced to ireland by lord martin
on the presentation of the gift itself
morphed decides to bring it back to his
home at castle howard in yorkshire and
theirs remains for 180 years that is
until 2009 when the lord morpheus row
was discovered in the castle howard
archives
my name's louise woolsworth bell i'm a
paper conservator
and part of the team that worked on the
mallpath role well this is the spool on
which the morphe roll was rolled and it
would have fitted into this chest there
are enormous difficulties with handling
a document of that size so it was really
important that we would make the object
handleable
digitization has massively facilitated
research
the beauty of coming to ancestry is that
i can type in the name of an ancestor
i'm looking for we search then all of
the documents that we have and if we
find a match you can click on the image
and actually see that digital image
ancestry has probably created electronic
indexes from handwritten documents more
than anyone else in the world
we use an overhead digital camera with
lighting to highlight the writing on the
page and move it a frame at a time so
that we can make sure we preserve every
stroke of the pen every color variation
in the parchment at the end after we've
captured every single image those are
stitched together in a document that now
appears online
i think the beauty of the digitization
of the role by ancestry is it enables
access not only here within ireland but
worldwide so it becomes accessible this
role actually reaches out now to a much
wider international community the
records that the content team at
ancestry of searching out and digitizing
and range from yearbooks with photos in
them to the military file of your great
grandfather as he served in world war
one whatever the record type our goal is
to bring the richest experience of
connecting with your ancestors
[Music]
you